hold on one second i'm going to  use my handy orphan alpha sunburn  computation thing  so long as i can get network here there  we go  oh actually you know what it says  sunburn unlikely  this is a qa moment  this is a good moment okay okay well  let's let me just check what it thinks  that i see why it thinks that it doesn't  seem like my intuition this is one of  these cases where we can the question is  do we do  do we trust the science or do we um use  common sense  the uv thing is called the yeah yeah  well we'll see this is a qa moment as i  say  it's uh can we trust the product yes we  trust the product so and then be a data  point  either way if if i'm desperately  sunburned i will send  an angry feedback  you